great news for rich white people and not
great news for everyone else the Urban
Institute said in a YouTube video though
the United States is one of the
wealthiest countries too many Americans
this prosperity remains out of reach
blacks and Hispanics who are striving to
make a better life for themselves and
their families are not given the same
asset building opportunities as the
video notes a white person in their 30s
in 1983 had an average net worth of one
hundred and eighty four thousand dollars
today these whites who are in the early
60s have accumulated 1.1 million dollars
in wealth blacks however when we saw
their wealth go from fifty-four thousand
to one hundred and sixty one thousand
Hispanic wealth has only grown from 46
thousand to two hundred and twenty-six
thousand all right well you can't argue
with the numbers I'm here with white
people the worst kind of people white
people look at the way your wealth you
freakin white people well technically
I'm a pink person king of the pink
people yes oh that's between y'all yeah
but I hate white people
I'm very Irish I'm like of the worst
it's white white so if you look at those
numbers I mean it really is kind of
staggering like something like but for
white people that value increased
something like six fold for black people
it was a little more than two I think
Hispanics not great also so you know
everyone wants to say we're post-racial
it seems like we've had a major slide
back into racial stuff in the last two
years
where where are we with the racial thing
and economics in America depressed yeah
it's just it's depressing I saw that and
I was just depressed and I thought I'm a
white person and I don't know what the
hell to do about it I don't I it's just
gonna get worse they would ask mantle or
social security every little safety net
in this culture so at any any support
that these communities have they want to
wipe out they they're not interested in
helping you know the Republicans and
them the power elite are not interested
in in creating and you know in a society
in an economy where everyone really gets
to prosper right so I think the
Republicans would argue they want
everyone to have this even playing field
and if there
an even playing field as there should be
I don't know what that means really but
that's an a text but then when you but
when you look right so does this really
what you're seeing here really is just
how systemic racist or racism or racial
not latest stuff is in the system that
it's just in this it's ingrained look I
mean was the Supreme Court yesterday
handed down the decision they would not
hear the Wisconsin voter totally racist
bias Wisconsin voter ID law so it stands
so now if you don't have a state
government issued driver's license or a
form of state issued government ID you
can't vote in Wisconsin right and you
know math still is math I mean it was
math when I woke up this morning so how
does it affect who does it affect it if
it affects people of color like a ten to
one because it's an extra expense and if
I lose my license like I don't want to
go and fent spend twenty six bucks that
I would spend on food to get another
license and they just make it harder for
people of color to vote and and and the
thing is also you know this is also
about obviously this is a racial issue
here but we're also talking about just
the general working poor right there
there's no way out of this stuff right
the general disparities in this country
look at the last presidential election
let's go back to math for one second
Obama won by two hundred and you know
it'll be comments about this two hundred
twenty six thousand votes they estimate
that nine percent of wisk
Wisconsin ian's was not the whatever
they are nine percent which is about
350,000 don't have this ID right there
it is Obama doesn't win Wisconsin right
so everything is motivated chipping away
they say one thing about a level playing
field and then they do everything they
can to just never do anything like that
and hurt people of color which is why I
hate white people I mean I absolutely
cannot stand white people so 300,000
people don't vote Obama do that
state-by-state there's seven other
states that happiness now that's how
they will gerrymandering and that is how
they will take the White House is how
they'll keep the Senate so when we
talked earlier in the earlier segments
about well you know the right we just
have to kind of get motivate off them I
said they're so dangerous this kind of
stuff if you're not motivated before the
election that's why we don't win the
midterms you're gonna watch everything
that you to your great point all the
social services that are barely there
now
are gonna go away because they're
rigging the game yep so less all right
is there no is there anything that Obama
can do because I think if you would have
asked the average person I voted for him
twice if you were to ask the average
person will race relations and some of
this systemic stuff and thumbs up will
it be better by the time he leaves he's
only got about 20 to some odd months
left it doesn't look like things are
gonna be better either economically or
just in terms of racial tension by the
time he leaves is there anything he can
do no because the owners of this country
own everything and they've got the power
whether it's you know it's Wall Street
isn't one of the owners now I mean I
know we're talking about some high-level
stuff that you're bad none of course he
is of course he is I mean you know I
mean I look at my my I'm not a person
makes a ton of money but I'm way up in
that ten percentile fifteen percent I
don't know it's insane to think about
that but the people who really own all
of the power and have all the cash in
this country they're not interested in
changing the system and there's a few of
them that are and and bless them for
that but they've got all the power you
know the money is the power right now
and it's been going this way for the
last thirty years
since since Reagan I mean especially
when the neo-cons really started
plotting all of this thirty years ago
they've done a great job and it was a
great country and I really don't know if
it ever will go yeah I'm for roadside
sterilization of white people and I
think if you're if you're a person of
any any racial hue a roadside roadside
you know I could be like you know you
get your oil change and snip snip so
Anna burger and if you're of any racial
just start having more babies because
the only way you're gonna change this is
to have such an electorate of color but
that is coming so here's California we
will be the bowtie sterilizations yeah
alright I have a feeling the commenters
are gonna have a field day with Chad by
the way his Twitter is at Chad
underscore I'm binder I think I got that
right and what this whole segment
reminds me of is the great quote from
father legendary George Carlin which is
they call it the American dream because
you have to be asleep